تبدو اماره دبي واثقه من قدرتها على تحقيق
حلم التحول الى عاصمه ل الاقتصاد الاسلامي
فهي متاكده من امتلاك البنيه التحتيه
والقانونيه والماليه اللازمه لمنافسه
مراكز تقليديه مثل المنامه وكو لمبور
وخططها تتجاوز التمويل لتصل الى المنتجات
الحلال
كالاطيار والتي ما زالت الفجوه كبيره في
المتوفر منها
اسلاميا الفرص الليمو موجوده قدامنا اليوم
حتى في بعض المصادر تذكر ان عدد او حجم
الانفاق على المنتجات هذه
يعتبر بشكل كبير يعني في
العام في
2000 مع نهايه 2012 اعتقد كان الانفاق حول
المنتجات الاغذيه فقط الحلال يفوق
الترليون دولار امريكي وهذا بس فقط على
الاغذيه فلا يشمل ايضا مستحضرات التجميل
ومستحضرات الصيدلانيه هاي فرصه موجوده
لاستقطاب عدد اكبر
من المنتجين والعاملين في هذا القطاع سواء
كانوا شركات تصنع منتجات حلال او شركات
توزيع المنتجات الحلال ايضا العاملين في
في
مجال طرح الشهادات شهادات المنتجات الحلال
وتبرز تجربه اجتذاب سقوق هونغ كونج التي
كانت الاولى من نوعها بالنسبه للحكومه
الاسيويه تدرج باسواق دبي كنموذج لمشاريع
الامارات على الصعيد
المالي احنا هدفنا
الاساسي الترويج عن امكانيه دبي لاستقطاب
هذه الصكوك
تسهيل عمليات خلينا نقول الادراج بما فيه
الاجراءات وكذا ها من اختصاصات الاسواق
سواء سوق نازداك دبي ولا سوق دبي المالي
لكن الكل ماشي على الاستراتيجيه
الاستراتيجيه مالتنا
تكوين دبي عاصمه للاقتصاد الاسلامي تشمل
عده محاور مثل ما ذكرت لك وكون ان هونج
كونج عزمت انها تدرج في دبي هاي طبعا
تعتبر بالنسبه لنا تعزيز مكانه دبي كعاصمه
للصاد الاسلامي لكن ايضا تعتبر مصدر ثقه
للحكومات الاخرى ايضا يعني وتؤكد دبي
قوتها ومكانتها بالمنافسه مع مراكز
تقليديه للتمويل الاسلامي مثل المنامه او
المنتجات الاسلاميه مثل ق لمبور اعتمادا
على مقومات بشريه وطبيعيه وجغرافيه
وقانونيه دور مدينه دبي في في مجال
الاقتصاد بشكل عام دور محوري يعني على
مستوى العالم يعني دبي معروفه ب مكانها
الاستراتيجي حول الاسواق الناشئه وايضا
الاسواق العالميه دبي دائما كانت مركز
تجاره حول
العالم ف البنيه التحتيه اللي موجوده في
اماره دبي بنيه تحتيه قويه وتقدر وهذا
الشيء يقدر يساعد تطوير الاقتصاد الاسلامي
على على شكل اكبر الاطار القانوني التي
يشتغلون فيه الشركات والمؤسسات مهم جدا
ايضا ودبي معروفه في هذا في هذا
المجال الاتصال والتواصل مع الاسواق
العالميه هذا هذا الشيء مهم جدا ايضا خاصه
في مجال التمويل او في قطاع التمويل ويلفت
الى ان دبي تطمح لترسيخ مكانتها بين المدن
المنافسه على هذا الصعيد قطاع التمويل
الاسلامي ولا قطاع الحلال مش مقتصر فقط
على مدينه ولا على على مكان معين بالعكس
احنا نبغ نروج عن التجاره العالميه نبغى
نستخدم دبي وامكانيه دبي ان تفعل دور
التجاره العالميه من هذا المكان فالرؤيا
شامله والرؤيه تكون واسعه مش مقتصره فقط
على هذه الاماره يعني الاص ولد سؤاله عن
الخيارات التي تتطلع ويها دبي على الصعيد
تنظيم عمليه الافتائي ووضع المعايير وما
اذا كانت ستختار بين مركزيه الافتائي او
لا مركزيته اجب العور اليوم الباب مفتوح
احنا هدفنا ان
نحاول نخلق هذا الحوار ما بين المعنيين
سواء الجهات سواء اللي
هم علماء الدين علماء اللي موجودين من ضمن
الشريعه بوردز في او مجالس الشورى في في
البنوك
او اذا كان
منظمين للخدمات
الماليه نباهم شوي يتكلمون اكثر مع بعض
نباهم يصلون الى اتفاق معين سواء كان
تكوين منظومه اللي هي يسمونها السلف ريلات
ابروش اللي
هي المنظومه اللي هي تديرها مجالس الشورى
في البنوك او المنظومه الاخرى اللي هي مثل
ماليزيا مثل ما تفضلت اللي هو يعتبر
سنترال شريعه بورد ويكون كل شي محكم عن
طريق محكمين التمويل مصطفى العرب سي ان ان
بالعربيه
دبي